serge gainsbourg cette semaine vous
allez être l'homme de la télévision
toujours à épisodiquement un chauffeur
de taxi et me dit vous appuyez vous va
plus à la télé là ils m'ont pas vu parce
que j'étais partie de moi donc
aujourd'hui j'ai tourné un film on va
cette semaine va me voir s'il va être
très content parce que vous avez trois
émissions
oui à vidocq qui va durer treize
semaines tous les samedis moi je fais la
musique d'une chanson replonge
génériques
il y a un nouvelle émission qui
s'appelle dans les landes où je fais des
génériques
puis un duo musical oui cette comédie
musicale pour vous c'est un grand
événement c'est la première comédie
musicale que vous composez oui ça c'est
une évolution intéressante pour un
auteur parce que on a une heure et demie
pour s'exprimer
comment se fait-il que vous ne composent
y est presque exclusivement que pour des
femmes je pleure
parlez nous de ces interprètes féminines
au malgré qu il ya enfin il ya eu pas ce
que je lui ai fait des infidélités mais
fait aussi
enfin on se retrouvera toujours oui qu
il ya des tulipes es-tu là c'est une des
rares qui me déçoit jamais dansé dans
ses interprétations
les actrices
bardot me wade a expliqué karine que
pensez vous d'elle en tant qu'interprète
de vos chansons
mais moi je touquet plus professionnelle
comme chanteuse qu'une une vraie
professionnelle
d'ailleurs je vais faire je lui ai
promis quoi me et 6 sur contrat signé
douze titres être tous composer un coup
pour france gall ou pour tous vu à ses
débuts
battus et du tarn
moi un toit
toute une école bébé america mes mails
ou tu as des temps de l'es1 des dents de
loup board
maintenant
baj
je suis cinglé mais oui j'ai de vtt ne
l'aide
est-ce que vous retournez à la chanson
en tant qu'interprète ça oui mais dans
une formule ambitieuse et d'avant garde
ben voilà alors là je lâche j'ai essayé
de me défendre la qualité
j'essaierai de faire une comédie
musicale à un personnage au lieu de
morceler un tour de chant deux minutes
trente deux minutes trente deux minutes
30 ou plus par les applaudissements et
bien on va essayer de faire une
continuité